Una recta pasa a través de los siguientes
puntos, y la ecuación de la recta está escrita
de la forma,
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
¿Cuál es la ecuación de la recta?
Ok y tenemos justa aquí la tabla, dándonos
los puntos por los cuales pasa esta recta.
Si te das cuenta, esta es la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen.
Y bueno, en esta ocasión creo que podemos
visualizar algo de una manera muy sencilla.
Si tu te das cuenta, creo que podemos sacar
"b" con mucha facilidad, porque "b" es la
intersección con el eje de las yes y aquí
lo tenemos de una manera muy sencilla,
porque cuando nosotros intersectamos al eje de las
yes, entonces "x" debe de valer 0.
En este caso, aquí en este punto, se ve claramente
qué es lo que pasa cuando "x"vale 0,
cuando "x" vale 0, intersectamos al eje de
las yes en el valor de 8/3, por lo tanto,
ya lo puedo escribir aquí, al menos ya sé
que "b" vale 8/3.
Ahora, falta encontrar la pendiente.
Y bueno, como no puedo escribir aquí voy
a pasar a mi libreta de notas,
para encontrar la pendiente de
esta recta que tenemos aquí, así que,
ok, aquí están mis notas y ya puedo trabajar
aquí la pendiente que nosotros necesitamos
encontrar, al menos ya sé cuánto vale "b".
Entonces vamos a escribir de nuevo esta ecuación
que tengo aquí...
y para esto déjenme cambiar a este pincel
y voy a poner justo esto...
"y"... "y" es igual a "mx" más... y "b"...
"b" vale 8/3, es el dato que me dan justo aquí.
Por lo tanto voy a sustituirlo aquí, 8/3.
Ahora date cuenta que podríamos encontrar
la pendiente como el cambio en "y" entre el
cambio en "x", sin embargo, voy a utilizar
otro de estos puntos para sustituirlo aquí,
en esta recta y así encontrar la pendiente.
Recuerda que todos estos puntos
pasan por esta recta.
Y por lo tanto me voy a fijar en este de aquí...
en este de aquí...
esto quiere decir que cuando "x" vale 1, "y"
vale 2, voy a sustituir justo aquí...
cuando "y" vale 2, entonces "x" vale 1...
"m" por 1, ok, más 8/3...
voy a conservar estos 8/3, ok.
Y ahora, voy a despejar a la pendiente, si
te das cuenta "m" por 1 es m, entonces esto
me va a quedar 2... 2 es igual a "m" por 1...
lo voy a poner con este color...
que es "m", ok, más 8/3... más 8/3...
ok, y como yo quiero despejar a la pendiente
para saber su valor, entonces voy a restar
8/3 de ambos lados de esta ecuación,
para que se cancelen estos 8/3,
así que aquí voy a quitar 8/3, ok,
y aquí también voy a quitar 8/3...
lo voy a poner así...
8/3 más 2, de tal manera que estos dos se
van y del lado derecho
solamente me queda la pendiente,
"m" es igual a 2 menos 8/3, pero si escribimos
al 2 en tercios, me quedan 6/3, 6/3 menos
8/3 es lo mismo que -2/3, de lujo,
ya tengo la pendiente.
La pendiente vale -2/3.
Y también ya tengo la intersección con el
eje de las yes que es 8/3.
Por lo tanto, regresemos a la página y vamos
a ponerle aquí que la pendiente vale -2/3.
Ok, vamos a ponerle aquí que mi pendiente
vale -2/3, ok
es hora de comprobar la respuesta y
¡perfecto, estamos bien!
Vamos a hacer otro ejercicio más para seguir
trabajando con este tipo de problemas.
Ok, perfecto, tengo ahora esta tabla de aquí.
Y bueno, en este caso también me dan de una
manera sencilla cuánto vale "b",
sin embargo, que te parece si trabajamos esta
misma tabla, pero ahora vamos a pensar
¿qué sería si no supiéramos el valor de "b"?
Y bueno, para resolverlo entonces, déjame
sacar por acá a mi libreta de notas...
ok, tenemos éste, vamos a quitarlo...
déjame quitar éste porque era el problema
anterior...
vamos a quitarlo...
Y vamos a poner ahora el nuevo problema.
Ok y dice,
una recta pasa a través...
ok, es lo mismo...
¿Cuál es la ecuación de la recta?
Muy bien, entonces me voy a tomar los dos
puntos más sencillos  para poder sacar la pendiente.
Recuerda que con dos puntos, es más que necesario
para encontrar la ecuación de una recta.
En este caso, como me dan un montón de puntos,
me dan más de dos puntos,
puedo elegir cuál de ellos me va a servir mejor...
y déjame mover un poco esto...
¿Cuál de ellos me va a servir mejor para
encontrar mi pendiente?
Y se me ocurre tomarme éste de aquí, ok,
y éste de aquí.
Entonces, vamos a fijarnos cuánto cambia
en "y" con respecto a cuánto cambia en "x".
Y bueno, si nos fijamos en "x" pasamos de
-2 hasta el 0 y por lo tanto, nuestro cambio
en "x"...
nuestro cambio en "x"...
va a ser igual a...
aumentamos 2...
aumentamos 2 de este punto a este punto.
Ahora, si nos fijamos en "y" pasamos de 0
a 2 y por lo tanto, el cambio en "y"...
el cambio en "y"...
bueno, pues aumentamos también 2
y por lo tanto, delta de "y" también es 2.
Y ahora sí, ya puedo decir que mi pendiente...
mi pendiente es exactamente lo mismo
que el cambio en "y" con respecto al cambio en "x", ok,
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2,
este 2 de aquí...
y déjame ponerlo con este color...
2 entre este otro 2... entre 2...
Por lo tanto, ya se que mi pendiente vale 1,
2 entre 2 es 1.
Y bueno, en el dado caso de que tú lo quieras
resolver en la forma habitual,
tú podrías decir, bueno, este es "y2" menos "y1", 2 menos 0 es 2, entre "x2" menos "x1", 0 menos -2
es 2, y 2 entre 2, otra vez me da 1.
Ok, ya tenemos la pendiente de esta recta
y entonces solamente falta encontrar el valor de "b".
Y bueno, ya que tenemos la pendiente, la podemos
sustituir en esta ocasión y entonces me quedaría
que "y" es igual a "m", pero "m" vale 1, 1
por "x" es "x", ok, más "b", ok,
"y"es igual a "mx" más "b".
Ahora lo que necesitamos saber es el valor de "b".
Y para sacar a "b"... bueno, lo podría hacer
muy fácil con este punto,
pero que te parece si utilizo otro distinto.
Y se me ocurre utilizar...
déjame poner esto por acá...
se me ocurre utilizar éste de aquí... ok,
voy a utilizar éste de aquí,
que dice que cuando "x" es 3, "y" vale 5...
cuando "y"vale 5, ok, entonces "x" vale 3, ok, más "b".
Y de aquí queremos despejar a "b", y por
lo tanto, vamos a obtener que "b"
es igual a 5 menos 3, ok,
lo cual es...
Oh, espérame...
que feo signo de igual...
lo cuál es 2, de lujo, "b" vale 2, que es
justo lo que teníamos aquí,
cuando "x" vale 0, intersectamos
al eje de las yes y ¡ok!
ya tenemos que la pendiente vale 1, "b" vale 2,
y entonces vamos a regresar aquí a la página
para escribir nuestras respuestas.
La pendiente... la pendiente valía 1, ok,
"b" vale 2,
y es hora de comprobar la respuesta y...
de lujo, estamos bien.